[Music]
113 questions about evolution with John
Perry hanging out with cousin Paige
Malibu Edition good mermaids actually a
ball could mermaids if all this is a
question I've gotten a lot there was a
documentary on like the Discovery
Channel I think it was like a fake
documentary about mermaids and I was
said I hate it when they do fake
documentaries on the Discovery Channel
but see I people haven't asked me on
this a lot could mermaids evolve some
people are asking me our mermaids real
like they actually think they might be a
real because there's all these stories
right I mean there is no evidence that
mermaids are real however on the
question of could they evolve or could
mermaids be real we do have an example
of this and that is whales right whales
started out as land animals and then
they went to the ocean so I suppose you
could have an ape or
a hominid group that evolves an aquatic
lifestyle I mean that can happen but it
won't be half-human half-fish bottom
right that would be weird yeah it's not
gonna be like some beautiful redhead in
a bikini and a shell bikini with like a
fishtail that's that's not gonna happen
but you could get I suppose you could
get like you know you could get Michael
Phelps to turn it to evolved into a you
know his offspring to evolve into like
marine people that are really good at
swimming he has he has had normally long
feet in hands for his body size a couple
other little weird traits and make him
extra good at swimming besides the fact
that he practices all the time but you
could get a population of humans to
evolve towards a marine lifestyle if
over thousands of generations you had
constant consistent intense selection
pressure that's only rewarding
individuals that are better and better
at hunting and
in the water so they're better at
swimming or holding their breath and
controlling their body temperature and
so on but by the time the population
became fully aquatic it wouldn't really
look human anymore right so if mermaids
that exist they wouldn't be these like
you know gorgeous women in the ocean
yeah but there is no evidence sadly that
mermaids exist there are a lot of
stories from sailor like older stories
from sailors and in history but it's
kind of hard to trust the testimony of
someone that's been out at sea for
months at a time
probably malnourished and maybe drunk
sorry that's just derogatory towards
sailors people who have these stories
well there's a beautiful woman on the
beach then she jump to the ocean and
swim away that's probably you're a long
ways away and you're seeing like seals
or something like that
flopping in the ocean and you're kind of
desperate cuz you haven't seen a woman
in years or months so doesn't look very
trustworthy those testimonies and you'd
think that by now because everybody has
a camera phone you think doesn't want to
have legitimate video and photos of
mermaids if they were indeed real
aquatic Apes if they were indeed real
there is actually a thing called the
aquatic egg hypothesis saying that a lot
of the differences between humans and
other apes might have been because maybe
we went through a semi-aquatic period in
our evolutionary history that other apes
did not go through like some people have
suggested that walking upright as a
result of that because when you're
wading through the water chimps and
stuff will do this when they wade
through the water it will stand up and
they'll walk like humans also the fact
that we had no fur you know maybe maybe
I was to help us swim faster or
something that doesn't make a whole lot
of sense though because a lot of aquatic
animals kwatak mammals have fur still
like seals
they have short fur but they still have
fur and there are other other ideas for
why we lost our hair that make more
sense like once once we had invented
clothing having less hair would actually
help for lice and things like that it's
easier to get rid of lice if you have
less less hair and there's pretty strong
evidence that we actually evolved not
for swimming but for running so a lot of
our aerodynamic properties of our bodies
are for running long distances which
yeah you can get down with that right
yeah also the way that we feel when it
run like people get addicted to
long-distance running our knees are very
different than the needs of other Apes
and those differences allow us to run
run long distances so there's the
Aquatic ape hypothesis is one that
there's just not a whole lot of data to
support it but it stays alive because
it's kind of cool idea tank that we were
we out the other thing that makes us
seem aquatic is that our fingers get
pruned in the water and that gives us
more grip and that's not just our skin
swelling with water that's actually like
unevolved trait could mermaids evolved I
suppose so
they wouldn't look like humans anymore
though and they definitely would not
look like Ariel and do mermaids exist
there's no good evidence for that so sad
[Music]
[Music]